ouah angela merkel et les dirigeants des
16 états allemands sont parvenus à un
accord si l'on peut dire
mardi pour prolonger le confinement les
écoles les salles de sport les commerces
non essentiels resteront fermés jusqu'à
fin janvier
les nouvelles mesures s'ajoutent
également à celles déjà adoptées
concernant les contacts en dehors du
foyer
on ne peut désormais rencontrés qu'une
seule autre personne venant d'un autre
foyer de plus dans les régions où les
nouvelles contaminations des passes de
son pour cent mille personnes
les déplacements seront restreints à 15
km du domicile au gué la merkel a
déclaré mardi après avoir trouvé cet
accord avec les chefs de région que ces
nouvelles mesures étaient nécessaires
certains épidémiologistes demandé des
mesures plus strictes mais le consensus
est très fragile entre le gouvernement
fédéral et les dirigeants des régions
l'accord était à peine trouvé que le
gouvernement de la basse-saxe
déclaraient qu'ils n'appliqueraient pas
les restrictions de déplacement des
responsables du bac vinterberg ont
déclaré qu'ils allaient étudier le
problème mais qu'il n'était pas enclin à
restreindre le déplacement dans leur
région poméranie occidentale
ils disent vouloir garder les écoles
ouvertes donc il n'y a pas encore de
véritable entente sur la gestion de la
situation
ce moment qu'un consensus se retrouve
chez les manifestants qui continuent à
protester contre les mesures de
confinement
le week-end dernier à nuremberg la
police anti émeute a dû intervenir
défendu le programme de vaccination ce
mardi où la lenteur est critiqué
cette semaine le ministre de la santé
higgins pam avait déclaré que totalement
souhaitant se faire vacciner devrait
pouvoir d'ici cet été
pour angela merkel
le déploiement avance à la bonne vitesse
et dans la bonne direction
ces nouvelles mesures approuvées plus ou
moins par les seize régions seront
revisités le 25 janvier pour décider si
elles seront prolongées en février